and Luca here at the forks and on
characteristic turnover again
Vanderbilt with the pressure on again
Jared Vanderbilt creating it
length has been valuable for the Lakers
but LeBron is quickly showing then
getting back to his man
he tipped it Dodge it started by
Vanderbilt puts up the three way off
good defense by the Lakers look at this
one for five when Jared Vanderbilt is
the primary defendant like that is we
call it the star it was a big matchup
Vanderbilt's presence has been huge
[Music]
Vanderbilt on doncicz took the contact
and left it short look at that length
athleticism the ability to stay in front
big time by Jared Vanderbilt at the
start of the game Vanderbilt versus Luca
would be an incredible matchup trying to
score over him look at the length makes
it a tough shot